باكستان حيث افاده مراسل الجزيره باصابه
عشرات المصلين في الانفجار داخل المسجد في
مدينه بيشاور عاصمه اقليم خيبر شمل غربي
باكستان ونقل مراسل الجزيره عن مسؤول امني
قوله ان المسجد يقع بالقرب من مقر لشرطه
المحليه وقد رفعت شرطه العاصمه حاله
التاهب الامريكان الانفجار الذي لم تعرف
اسبابه
اذا سنعود الى هذا الموضوع المزيد من
التفصيل
نتواصل مع مراسل الجزيره في اصابات طبعا
الانفجار وقع بالقرب من مقر للشرطه همم في
همم بشاور وادى الى سقوط عدد من المواطنين
الباكستانيين همم جرحها لحد
الانفجار وعن المزيد من التفاصيل عموما
همم هذا الانفجار سنواصل سنتابع يعني
تطورته
ونحاول ان نحصل على المزيد من المعلومات
بعد قليل مع مراسله الجزيره في اصابات